claude jolicoeur et président de
l'office national du film
c'est ma première j'ai tellement vu
chanter l'extérieur c'est très excitant
la lumière ces vastes vaste les futurs
bureaux de l'unef
il y aura quatre étages des espaces à
bureaux en plus l'office national du
film va occuper une partie du
rez-de-chaussée et toute la mezzanine un
grand dégagement noyer de lumière qui
servira des espaces publics
là vous êtes vraiment centre-ville on
est au centre-ville
on est au coeur de la création c'est de
les musées les artistes c'est un lieu
exceptionnel c'est mieux que ça prenait
pour le web parce qu'en ce moment on
sent larchitecture de 1956 quand
vêtements et les couleurs qui ont pas
changé c'est presque un hôpital
l'immeuble un grand complexe
cinématographique inaugurée en 1956 à
installer au nord de montréal à ville
saint-laurent on était presque à la
campagne aujourd'hui un concessionnaire
automobile comme voisin perdu le long de
l'autoroute métropolitaine
on a en étant un loup à neuf le même
sentiment d'éloignement d'isolement set
au n 9 qui fut jadis prospère en 73 on
avait même ajouté à l'arrière une grande
annexes l'édifice aujourd'hui est
complètement vides abandonnées
l'industrie a changé et puis des coupons
frapper encore et encore un moment donné
vous avez été 1200 employés à 1200 après
jc on et 250 maintenant alors là on
rentre dans un lieu magique
suzanne animations catherine bouchard
bonjour que révèle l'autopsié sur le
corps de la victime que l'essentiel a
survécu lohan est fade gardé ses forces
vives en animations comme ici patrick
bouchard qui met la dernière main à son
film d'animation jeunes par
l'improvisation mais c'est un film qui a
été qui a été écrit offert un truc s'est
tournée donc il ya toutes sortes et les
mac sont sortis un peu sur le sous thème
de l'eau dans la pièce d'à côté c'est
jean françois lévesque qui fait aussi un
film d'animation
cette fois dû miniature vous garder ses
studios en garde tous on a créé de
nouveaux espaces au centre-ville pour
qu'ils soient adaptés aux besoins des
cinéastes avec des plafonds plus élevé
des conditions d'éclairage adapté savoir
garder savoir réduire lohan est factuel
à deux théâtres qui comptent ensemble
plus de 300 places
le nouvel édifice en aura un seul 2 135
sièges
le grand studio de son existera toujours
mais sera plus petit et puis que faire
de ces centaines d'accessoires qui
servent à créer du champ les trois
quarts ne survivront pas aux
déménagements
quand c'est juste du papier qui sert à
simuler le crépitement du feu
ça va bien le crépitement est ce que
c'est que ce sont des pentes d'auto way
pour faire quoi ça pour faire des bruits
métalliques avec de la résonance vous
allez pour les ménages de sa wii est
frais il faut il faut parce que c'est
trop utile ça ça va déménager
ces dernières années loin nef a aussi
beaucoup investi dans la réalité
virtuelle les nouveaux médias le
déménagement au centre ville pourrait
favoriser secteurs émergents la majorité
des projets qu'on fait en productions
interactives sont faites en
collaboration avec le nom d'organisation
comme le quartier des spectacles par
exemple donc cette proximité là je pense
vont favoriser davantage de
contamination davantage de collaboration
alors ici on est dans la voûte de la nef
et puis quoi faire de la vous de cette
immense voûte qui contient deux cent
quatre-vingt mille éléments la voûte
n'ira pas au centre-ville mais sera
déménagée dans la région montréalaise
dans un immeuble à trouver entre temps
tous les films sont numérisés image par
image vieux film 16 mm de 30 minutes
prend 14 heures à numériser
qu'adviendra-t-il de l'édifice de l'onef
il est question de le préserver des
pourparlers sont en cours avec la ville
et héritage montréal
on se moque à la blague de son côté
austère mais l'édifice a une âme ici
sont passées notamment denis arcand
jacques godbout andré melançon pierre
perrault micheline lanctôt alanis
obomsawin léa pool philippe falardeau
denis villeneuve et si on se force
vraiment pour chercher des qualités à
cet édifice du bout du monde on en
trouve
est-ce qu'elle a d'être un défaut
devient aussi ne peut devenir une
qualité
le défaut de nfc d'être si loin laquelle
telle aux élèves parce que c'est si loin
c'est d'avoir souder les les gens qui
travaillent ici donc on est condamné à
manger ensemble et c'est ce qui est
chouette le midi à la caf on se côtoie
beaucoup comme mieux rien à faire
d'autre ici vous est condamné à créer
avec ce déménagement lohan f-15 plus que
des nouveaux locaux quand on est sûrs go
c'est vraiment un gage
d'avenir pour le one est ici parce qu'on
fait pas un chantier comme ça pour cette
fois un édifice à bureaux et services à
10 10 est là pour rester on est là pour
rester on inclut tout le monde 250
employés côte de liesse
ils viennent aussi si ils sont bientôt
c'est qu'ici on ne répondra donc au plan
non l'emporté sur tout déménagement
prête en 2019
tous ensemble avec en poche un bail de
20 ans